no solo
[Música]
muy buenos días a todos es un gusto
poder estar hoy aquí con compartiendo
con todos ustedes cívicos y bueno poder
platicar un poquito de lo que es la
industria sin chimenea voy a platicar
van a decir como en este tiempo de
pandemia podemos hablar del tema
turístico como podemos hablar de las
agencias de viajes cuando hemos tenido
un proceso que primero todo lo que fue
el internet toda esta innovación de
plataformas de centros nuevos donde la
mayoría de las personas se convertían en
su propio agente de viajes pues cuando
les voy a platicar un poquito de la
experiencia que he tenido
en el ramo turística al que nosotros le
llamamos la industria sin chimenea
porque la industria sin chimenea porque
es una industria que que no contamina es
una industria que ha avanzado a pasos
agigantados por todo el mundo y bueno la
parte que a mí me tropo desde mi
trinchera fue fue una parte muy bonita
la cual
para compartir el día de hoy cómo surgió
cómo surgió esto de la agencia de viajes
cómo surgió el empezar a hacer esta
parte turística empezar a innovar
algunas cosas y pues bueno todo fue muy
sencillo yo estaba realmente en la
preparatoria cuando todavía no sabía
exactamente qué era lo que quería
estudiar pero sí tenía muy claro algo
que algo que disfrutaba era viajar mis
padres siempre dijeron que el viajar te
enseñaba y que cada que regresaba de un
viaje traías una perspectiva diferente
de la vida de las cosas aprendidas a
valorar más y efectivamente no se
equivocaron que fue iniciamos mi hermano
y yo empezamos diciendo oye como ves si
organizamos entre tus amistades y mis
amistades y pues hacemos una pequeña
excursión en aquel momento todavía se
llamaba reino aventura no se llamaba
como basics blacks y pues bueno esté
entre nuestros amiguitos de la
preparatoria pues dijimos vamos a hacer
un viaje
emprenderemos nuestro primer viaje claro
teníamos un antecedente nuestros padres
nos enseñaban mucho esta parte de el
campamento las actividades el poder
compartir con los demás compañeros el
poder ayudar
teníamos muchos grupos y pues iniciamos
esto cuando pensamos que era solamente
una pequeña reunión entre amigos entre
chicos preparatorianos y pues bueno cuál
fue nuestra sorpresa que en un grupito
que creíamos que íbamos a ir unos diez
los terminamos siendo un autobús de 45
personas y pues bueno este pues nuestra
primera experiencia con el turismo de
ahí pues empezamos a tratar de hacer
algo distinto por lo que ya habíamos
aprendido pues en los viajes no era
solamente vámonos de viaje y conoce a
algo no íbamos teniendo actividades
desde que subíamos al camión desde que
subíamos a la camioneta ya les iba
enseñando de qué forma ir interactuando
empezamos lo que nosotros le llamábamos
el rompehielos
por qué pues porque muchas veces qué
hacemos cuando viajamos pues se trata de
que vayas conociendo no solamente el
lugar al que llega sino también a las
personas que están a tu alrededor que
dejemos de estar solamente en nosotros
mismos y vayas abriendo este ese nuevo
panorama de poder tratar con mucho más
personas y saber sus experiencias
entonces así fue así fue como empezamos
con este con este tema este camino bueno
después queda aquí en el george si yo
seguimos diferentes caminos pero si les
puedo decir que empecé empecé con este
tema empecé a organizar a organizar
viajes
al principio primero salíamos y salíamos
de lo que era nuestra ciudad y
conocíamos otros lados pero después
empecé con una inquietud dice bueno es
muy par de que vayas y conozcas muchos
lados pero qué pasa porque no vienen a
que conozcan hoy mi estado porque no
viene me conoce en veracruz que tenemos
tantas cosas que ofrecer y así esto
empezó a ir creciendo empecé a reunirme
pues me empecé a ir a los pueblos a los
son los mágicos que tiene veracruz y
empecé a preguntar quiénes eran las
personas que ofrecían que era lo que
estaban haciendo para que se dieran a
conocer para que pudieran ofrecer algo
nuevo
empecé por ejemplo en un lugar que se
llama mágico que hay una panadería que
ya lleva muchas generaciones donde su
pan es un pan hecho a base de hornos de
leña y pues bueno entonces platicando
con ellos les dije qué posibilidad
habría de que yo traiga a al turista y
no solamente que vean cómo están ustedes
haciendo su pan sino que les demos la
oportunidad
que ellos aprendan a hacer una pieza de
pan ustedes les enseñen cómo hacen su
pan y entonces no les vamos a cobrar
cuando estén haciendo su pan pero sí les
puedo garantizar una cosa que mientras
ustedes meten al horno el pan nosotros
vamos a hacer un recorrido por lo que va
a ser todo el pueblo y seguramente
cuando terminemos el recorrido y antes
de salir de aquí podrán pasar van a
llevar su pieza de pan pero no solamente
eso le está seguro que casi todos
llevaban bueno bolsas completas de pan y
entonces empezamos a dejar una derrama a
donde íbamos ya una derrama para la
gente que estaba alrededor igual lo
hicimos con el que fabricaba el molde
con el que hacían los toritos sea
vivíamos la experiencia por qué por qué
y el turismo no solamente es llegar y
conocer nosotros empezamos con esa
innovación de vivir experiencias que te
lleves algo que te lleves algo que estás
aprendiendo y que no solamente es el
estar directamente y dices wow qué lugar
tan bonito no sino que estoy yo haciendo
juego después compartirles y díganme por
favor si en estos momentos que les estoy
platicando nos están imaginando esas
emuladas nos están imaginando ese
pancito que están metiendo al horno de
leña y su cafecito de la zona de
coatepec sí verdad entonces pues claro
así así fue la experiencia que empezamos
nosotros a quererle transmitir al viajar
al viajero al visitante al turista y de
esa misma forma pues bueno lo empecé a
hacer en los diferentes lados que iba
conociendo de las entidades quién era
hay a ver quién es el artesano por
ejemplo en naolinco nos pasaba un señor
que me decía antes que es el más caro es
el más caro bueno pues llamé con uno mas
barattero estaciones del más caro podría
me con el mas barattero no no es que le
decimos del más caro porque hace más
caras
entonces que ocurrió pues efectivamente
el señor se dedicaba a hacer unas
máscaras preciosas porque porque en la o
lincoln tiene una de sus fiestas típicas
que es
de muertos y todos los habitantes salen
con unas máscaras y es se dedicaba a
hacer unas máscaras preciosas de
cualquier personaje que se puedan
imaginar y entonces van a llevarlos a su
casa a ver cómo qué cantidad de máscaras
tenía como las y batallando el que nos
enseñará un poquito pues se fue haciendo
parte de nuestras actividades que empecé
a ofrecer porque empecé claro haciendo
unas pequeñas excursiones y eso después
pues ya me hablaban por teléfono o sea
cuando yo ni siquiera estaba en la
universidad y hablaban a la casa de mis
padres y preguntaban hoy gana y es la
chica que hace excursiones ella es la
muchacha bueno para nada me quiera que
es la muchacha y así fue entonces usted
empecé con esa parte de ir así
organizando eso a la vez pues con el
tiempo me di cuenta que era importante
tener un transporte para que pues para
poder ofrecer un paquete más atractivo y
que tuvieran la facilidad de ir viajando
en los mismos transportes que
que podía ofrecerles entonces pues bueno
el transporte me llevó después a tener
que ofrecer comida típica de la región
está dónde íbamos entonces ya con tanto
ir conociendo pues me ponía con ellos
también ahí estar cocinando y que les
puedo decir sé que no me voy a extender
mucho porque tengo un tiempo limitado y
algo por aquí empiezo a platicar como un
periquito
efe no pero sí les puedo decir
que seguía un sueño que seguía algo que
a mí me gustaba que empecé a hacer algo
ya lo mejor muchas veces me dijeron no
no vas a poder no mirar cómo eres mujer
algo macro no se te dé esta oportunidad
pero sí les puedo decir que todos los
seres humanos cuando seguimos algo que
nos gusta lo vamos a hacer feliz yo
disfruto hoy muchísimo mi trabajo y este
mismo trabajo me ha dado la oportunidad
de conocer no solamente lugares sino
personas personas maravillosas que que
muchos se han seguido quedando en mis
vidas y yo las de ellos por qué pues
porque siempre vas poniendo un pequeño
granito de arena en lo que haces cuando
yo no le digo un granito de arena yo le
digo un granito de azúcar porque la
mitad soccer porque granjita su cuerpo
te va en dulce y entonces pues es lo que
hace tratando de que se que hagas esto y
pues bueno que ocurrió que hoy
resumiendo les así rápidamente pues
empecé con los viajes luego hice con la
agencia de viajes eso a la vez me hizo
poner una operadora
porque porque ya nosotros organizamos
los paquetes que podíamos ofrecer a las
demás agencias y que ellos pudieran
venderlas y entonces pues así fue como
cómo surgió la operadora turística
después la transportadora turística
después empezamos con todo el tema de
los caterings de ofrecer los alimentos y
ofrecer alimentos típicos si les puedo
decir que por ejemplo cuando a mí me
piden que organizamos exclusiones pero
también convenciones a grupos a que
vayan a hacer de su trabajo de las
empresas que vienen de muchas otras
partes de la república y siempre los
invito a que vayan a veracruz de acuerdo
a una de las de las más emblemáticas y
que me costó más de cuatro años
enamorarnos para que vinieran a veracruz
fue el colegio de contadores a nivel
nacional
ellos siempre me decían sabes qué gran
sí sí quiero que hagas astro lento pero
porque aún nos llevas a otro lugar
digamos no se sientan a rojo a mazatlán
y claro y si lo hice pero yo seguía
convencida que quería que vinieran a
veracruz porque si venía de si va a
gustar lo que iban a ver y claro no
estoy demeritando ningún otro estado
porque todos tienen un encanto precios o
sea todo el mundo tiene lugares
maravillosos pero qué pasó cuando
llegaron por fin de cuatro años y que me
dieron la oportunidad de poder
atenderlos
en mi estado una de las cosas que sí les
pedí que me dejaran que todo todo lo
organizada completamente al estilo de lo
que hacemos los veras constantes la
comida la música los espectáculos y
bueno y para cerrar con broche de oro o
sea quien fue a cerrar la noche fue un
artista veracruzana como yuri
un espectáculo que fue el espectáculo
jarocho un concierto con 100 arpas y hoy
todos podrían recordar que veracruz pues
tiene muchas muchas cosas no solamente
es la playa sino también tenemos
personas maravillosas que hacen que
veracruz se pueda hablar bien de él
entonces hoy qué es lo que estoy
haciendo
el consejo metropolitano de turismo y
que hace el consejo metropolitana de
turismo bueno pues es donde estoy
invitando a que no todo se vaya para el
puerto sino que también le demos esa
importancia a todos nuestros pueblos que
están alrededor que lleguen a xalapa y
que no pasen solamente sino que se
queden ahí que se queden y hoy estamos
trabajando
xalapa y coatepec xico naolinco pero
vote todo al comunicó todos los lugares
que están cercanos estamos haciendo esta
metrópoli y ofreciendo cada quien desde
su trinchera algo hermoso del lugar que
haga que tu experiencia sea diferente
hoy estamos enfocándonos a estos grupos
porque sabemos que por ejemplo hoy las
personas de la tercera edad ya tienen la
oportunidad de poder viajar pero también
pueden viajar con los nietos
y que padrino cuando a ver ustedes
recuerdan si viajas con tus abuelos
y les enseñas otra parte cada quien con
su respectivo chip bueno hoy es algo
también de lo que estamos empezando a
implementar y qué mejor oportunidad que
en la pandemia porque definitivamente de
todo tenemos que aprender y yo les puedo
decir que hoy en la pandemia a mí me
enseñó muchos pozos uno a saber generar
más dos empezar a hacer grupos y en
estos grupos poner a todas esas mujeres
empresarias que no sabían la gran
capacidad que tenían entre ellas tengo
una plataforma en donde hoy tenemos más
de 7500 mujeres a menos de dos meses de
haberse conformado y que todas ellas no
solamente hacemos un consumo local sino
también ofrecen ofrecen cosas que ni
ellas sabían que podían elaborar y que
cada vez la hacen más más especializada
pues bueno muchas gracias
voy a tener que cortar porque el tiempo
que les dije que me podía aquí extender
de una hora
les puedo decir solamente que
definitivamente cuando uno quiere hacer
algo no puedes truncar tus sueños habrá
quien te diga que que no te es posible y
no quiere decir que pueda ser fácil todo
pero cuando hacemos las cosas con ganas
se van a lograr
muchas gracias que tengan un hermoso día
[Música]